No tenemos el compromiso
con la caja del seguro social
de volver a arreglar el sistema de pensiones,
pero también tan importante,
de mejorar la pensión médica
para que tengamos citas a tiempo,
medicamentos baratos
que no nos falten en el seguro
y en la caja del seguro social.
Eso sí, los medicamentos en la farmacia
no van a estar a los precios que están ahora
porque yo no represento
a las grandes farmacéuticas,
ni represento los intereses de las transnacionales
ni de los grupos económicos que sean beneficiados
a costillas de la salud de los panameños.
Les aseguro que no me temblarán la mano
para bajar los precios de los medicamentos